we're delighted to bring you this
seminar preserve my labyrinth in
collaboration with the National
Institute of Health welcome to our track
on the NIH brain initiative a
multidisciplinary approach to
neuroscience we're glad you could join
us today for this panel presentation
titled anatomical characterization of
neuron cell types in the mouse brain it
is my pleasure to introduce a panel of
experts who will be speaking on the
topic of resource and tool development
for full listening please click on the
tab at the top of your screen if any
questions are as during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the
Q&A box our speakers will respond to you
back via email as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming our panel of
experts hello everyone my name is Hong
Wade um professor of neurology at the
USC today I am the tool of my
collaborators dr. Georgia is calling in
the uncurl claim talk about our new one
grant that is funded by brain initiative
so the goal for this project is to
identify different cell types in the
mouse brain and on send each individual
cell types there's physical functions
and eventually and then how these
different cell types the contributed to
the neurological disease in a nurse at
Hydra disease in fact from Ramona coho
are really laid the grant foundation for
this kind of work and you can see his
beautiful joints he showed in the retina
has several different neuronal cell
types there's a different morphology and
the Centers of projections to the tectum
in the tectum also have different cell
types display different neuronal
morphology in fact in fact in the last
several decades and the whole
National Field is trying to do this work
um refine the anatomy identify different
cell types on Tanith as their local
secretaries and their long-range
projections so for our work also is the
same thing we focus on several different
aspect we systematically map long-range
connections from different brain regions
and in each new video brain regions we
try to catalogue different cell types
based on their neuronal morphology and
also defined their cells have a space
between your circuitry
all of this work eventually will be
hopefully well lived tune our ultimate
goal to understand how this thing how
these different the neural South heads
and also single neurons they are
input-output organizational principles
in a court today our talk I'm going to
focus on the first part to report our
progress of construct a hopper a wiring
diagram in a house is different
your Secretary's associative is
individual brain structures they put
together as the neural networks for
conducted different behaviors in
functions and I'm going to also lay the
framework for general strategies our
grant to how we systematically catalog
neuronal cell types and dr. Georgiou as
Colleen is going to talk in details how
we define South has based on their neuro
mythology and also another project
called a short gun project home the ANA
dr. Lim is going to present our effort
of developing cutting-edge technologies
to define the cell type-specific neural
circuit race so for ultimately what we
are really trying to understand it is so
if the individual neurons are building
blocks of the brain and I call this
individual neurons they are organized
together to conduct
a sophisticate shabbir this is exactly
follow the same principles just like an
individual channel cheese when they have
different combinations we can play
beautiful music cheese so a little bit
of background about our mouse connectome
project that was launched about 10 years
ago from my lab and it is the one of the
first fund brain initiative funded the
project the goal for this project is
constructing the whole brain 3d
connectivity atlas and here's a one
representative images to show we use a
different floor recent tracers to label
the different pathways you can see here
red colored by fibers and their
terminals and a green color axons and
their terminals at the same time we also
label the upstream neurons as we showed
his pink dots and so the challenge part
for us really is the in the mammalian
brain has about 800 to a thousand
well-defined brain structures how we can
systematically structure by structure
max their neural circuitry and then
putting together as neural networks and
so about 10 years ago we start from a
first look at linear circuits in the
cortex the whole cortex has about 16
different cortical areas we start look
at their Sur countries for each
individual cortical areas and then
eventually we'll put together as this
published work called neural networks of
the mouse neocortex and this work in
fact set up the entire frame work for us
to understand the whole central nervous
system on your circuitry is how they
organized so a little bit of background
that you see in terms of our techniques
so we for we use is called a chapter
tracing method to do the Stewart
accident injections the injections the
trees are seen through the mouse
for each injection we have a mixture of
one interpreted tracers and we show
here's the green color axons come from
injection site the label adds the MOS
secondary motor cortex these axons
project to the contralateral side their
terminals at same time in this the
injection site has a mixture of rich
operated cheezer's which can be picked
up by axon terminals by their upstream
neurons and enriched horridly
back label these neurons as we can show
here is the pink dot that's the upstream
neurons they project back to the
injection site so we do this using
somatic injections in injecting into the
entire cortex is about 300 injections
600 pathways and then eventually we put
together in a constructor this is the
most detailed connectivity map of the
entire cortical cortical connections and
what we find out is in fact the entire
cortical and all the different cortical
areas they are organized as a modular
sub networks for example in charge
somatic sensory motor areas include
primary sensory primary motor second
motor secondary matter centering they
are organized into several distinct
neural networks in conduct different
behaviors for example this blue color
labeled pathways they are organized by
several individual areas they're fully
connect with each other in the control
of our official movement and it is a
green color labeled pathways they are
organized by several areas there are
they're also fully connected with each
other
conduct in the controlled upper limb
movements and the right color pathways
control the lower limb
pathways so these modular networks allow
the censoring and emoto
areas
directly interact with each other and
can conduct with different sensory motor
functions so in contrast so this is same
facial area in auditory areas there are
highly connected with several other
areas called higher-order Association
areas they are distribute along the
media bank of the cortex these pathways
we put together as called the media
called core networks their process and
transmit with a visual auditory spatial
centuries to the prefrontal cortex
another side of networks that is a
cortical areas they are distributed
along the lateral edges of the cortex
include useful cortical areas temporal
Association area and also the intro no
cortical areas they are organized as so
called the lateral quad core networks in
these networks their process based rock
dust tree or factory information and
also function relate to self-awareness
so put it together we look at it in her
mouth cortex
they're organized into this about 10
different sub networks their conduct the
different functions and put all together
all the different individuals of
networks they are convergent onto the
prefrontal cortex in a somatic sensory
subah networks they cut they're
converging onto the dorsal lateral
prefrontal areas and the media and the
lateral cortical areas that they are
converged on the ventral medial cortical
areas if we look at on the flat map of
the mouse brain we can see the entire
cortical areas they organize into the
different segments of the networks there
circulate draw out intercut whole
hemisphere so what happened
after we map the entire quad core quad
core networks the next step is we we are
trying to understand individual cortical
areas and also their Sabaa networks
there are projections to difference of
cortical structures so the first third
structure were looking at is a stratum
because the stratum received all three
own individual cortical areas is a
general generated projections to the
strident and Australia music playing
important functions in the control of
the motor combination and other
important functions
this also is published work and we put
together as is the mouse carcass title
project home and we maybe beat you
cortical areas and a generator is a very
detailed cortical stratum projection map
and then and you can see here each
individual cortical areas is a
projection the stratum the our display
is teaching projection patterns and then
we did the quantification and we did a
network analyse and then we look at from
how the different cultural areas and
also their different sub networks how
the projection stratum based on this
their projection patterns we basically
subdivide interest rate immune to the
z11 religion bill otter communities and
29 smaller functional domains and when
we look at the how they works we find
out actually the the cortical areas they
are organized as super networks the
displayed overlap projection patterns
minister item for example what are we
showing here is the entire
somatic sensory motor cortex remember
they are organized they are organized as
four parallel pathways
lincolnshire or official upper limb
lower limb
functions nae each sub networks has
matter sensor is matomoto areas they
heavily connected with each other in the
cortical areas and then their projection
terminals in the stratum they are
overlapped so from this map what we can
see here is trunk areas of networks they
project you the religion beat also parts
and there is a lower limb there is upper
limb and then all our official relates
the Calico areas they project your
ventral lateral side of the stratum put
together we form this kind of
upside-down homunculus
projection patterns and then the media
cultural networks these different
cortical areas the project mostly to the
dorsal medial stratum cortical areas
between the laterals sub networks the
project you laterals eventually eventual
medial side of the stratum but however
one wish really should pay attention is
each individual cortical areas their
projection pattern in the stratum they
are very unique but you could call each
individual stratum the man's will
receive converging inputs from a unique
a subset of cortical areas put all
together we generate this hypothesis a
functional model of the dorsal striatum
the basically is a 20-9 functional
domains they receive unique different
cortical input for example this here we
show you in the middle of the stratum
next to the lateral ventricles blue
color
vertical stripes there it receives
basically input from primary visual
cortex
internal cortex which speaks their
function in the based on spatial
integration in a bunch of lateral side
of stratum received space to be new for
the from all the oral facial related
somatic sensory motor cortical areas
then after we look at you
corkle strata projections obviously the
next question natural questions how this
different individual stratum demands
what is their downstream protection
patterns so we then made the injections
into all these individual functional
domains of stratum and look at how the
stratum project is the downstream
structures the pallidum [ __ ] and then
project back to the Salam's hopefully we
can finish this work in short amount of
time so the next question really is
asking how the coracle project others
subcortical structures for example
here's the superior colliculus and for
this power work we also generate called
the mascot core tectal project on
canada's also analyzed many injections
in the cortical areas and then we put
together these papers unpublished data
we used about 86 called textual
projection pathways and the same thing
we look at each individual cortical
areas their projections to the stratum
you know accordingly based on these
connectivity patterns we subdivided the
superior colliculus into four different
columns and as we can show here as a
different columns receive the convergent
input from different cultural areas for
example the lateral side of this column
receive all the input from somatic
sensory motor areas in a media column
receive input from visual and your
cingulate and other cortical
input to relate to the visual you know i
movement and then we make mean jack
injections into the superior colliculus
and then put together this a wiring
diagram of the entire colliculus and so
this is our general strategy step by
step and then eventually we're going to
map the connectivity for the
bring in her brain and also look at how
the different searches put together at a
club on your networks so and another
really important set of the cortex is
that is called the limbic system classic
limbic system they are organized by half
chambers amygdala and immediate
prefrontal cortex the their projection
patterns mostly to the hypothalamus and
the in the control of this emotional
related behavior so for this part we
also made a good progress we put
together of this the temple connectome
paper and for these people a little bit
different is we also look at how the
connectivity relate to the gene
expression patterns so the general
strategy is we systematically analyzed
about 2,000 genes from allenbury address
database located in the each individual
component of offenders for example see
to hear which genes press in the c2 and
which genes need to the different
segments of the c3 c1 speak lon and then
based on this gene pressure patterns we
subdivide each individual sample
component into the different molecular
demands after that and then we exam each
moniker demands what their input output
and then put together the 3d atlas of
the hippocampus and also have Campeau
wiring diagram as we showed here this is
the each individual moniker demands they
display the unique patterns of the gene
pression
will also be correlated with the neurons
they send projections to different
projection targets and once we put
together from this map you know we also
look at each individual brain individual
have a tempo moniker demand so what is
their global projection patterns
for example like here showed different
neuronal populations in the instrument
cortex they project you to a different
component of this is Vikram and also
their predictions to the mammary body
and then cheer together we put this a
happy camper wiring diagram this one you
can find from our website so you know
when clicked together it's a global
learning diagram that will help us that
you really refine the anatomy and then
identifying each individual brain
structures well this is smaller
subdivisions and then further subdivide
look at each individual's most of the
divisions the how many difference out
has there and then look at how this
different cell types of what is their
unique connecting patterns that will
help us eventually understand their
unique behavior and functions and so
after we put together the wiring diagram
for each individual brain structures we
look at their axonal projections and
then we start new this called projection
defined south hex and then to the
catalog neuronal populations need to
different subpopulations based on their
connectivity just like what I showed
here is a region one individual region
they project you multiple targets and
each individual regions they have these
different cell types and then we make
injections of rich chocolate tracers
into their different cell types and then
the back label neurons in their regions
and then we look at which neurons
project one targets or two targets or
different targets so the prediction
happen the strategies that we use the
angular industries are looking at their
projection criminals and then you'll
reach oh great the tracers look at you
find the different neuronal populations
and then we currently look at it there
and that homie with distributions and
then look at their morphology and then
characterize their cells have specific
approaches and patterns
as what I showed here that is the we
define is the temples different moniker
domains and then making objections of
reach over it treaters into their
different targets for example in the
last sections here yellow color that is
an injection reach over users into the
thalamus back levels the yellow neurons
they are distributed the unitive layers
of speak lon
the all Islamic projection neurons and
this design project this pink neurons
the project to the media mammillary body
and it's the thin layer four in color
labeled neurons they project you
letterman memory nucleus and then we
look at characterize how these neurons
the project one targets or different
targets and then we do the
quantification whichever characterize
their different population based on
their production targets and then we can
match them with their molecular domains
so this is the ongoing work and
hopefully in the future we can also use
the different approach to look at an
exactly the same neurons and look at
similar ins which monochrome occurs
there in press then obviously after we
look at its individual neurons where
they project you and we use the release
labeling we can also reveal your
detailed neuronal mythology as well we
can show here this green color neurons
the project intervention slamming
nucleus you can see there the this
neuron display extremely complex
dendritic mythology's
which is again indicate how the
information can be processed in these
neurons and also we can't map the axons
from these neurons and these different
colors the represent different neurons
is the red color neurons project or
reunion ceramic nucleus and in the pink
neurons here project you reaches playing
areas and also we knew this the same
strategy
label different neuron populations also
look at it into other different brain
structures such as superior colliculus
we have a developed new informatics
tools to characterize their neuronal
morphology and also chat logins the
different neuronal populations the under
dr. Joe Joe as Colleen is going to feel
more detailed talk about it some how we
characterize neurons based on their
morphology and also dr. Lim is going to
talk about how we characterize these
cell types and then define their self
have specific in your circuitry's and
also we have collaborations with other
groups followed by brain initiative we
gather their molecular signatures and
also Physiology functional properties
this work we have well developer
collaborations through our you'll one
grant and also with other brand other
groups opponent Viper English T's and
finally I want to acknowledge my lab
results aim this work cannot be done in
such skill and also I really appreciate
up my whole group and also my
collaborators Giorgio as Cody and Bianca
name the attention and also other
collaborators we are working together on
other projects also funded by brain
grants hello my name is Jorge
elastically I'm professor at George
Mason University in Fairfax Virginia
and today I'm going to follow through
the tale of hungry bank
describe to talk about two projects one
is the database of neuron reconstruction
odds that is very much inspired penny to
catalog all neuron types this is based
on morphology and the other is a very
novel way of analyzing projection type
based on retrograde retrograde tracked
rate which was introduced in Hong ways
top
so the importance of morphology
neuroscience has been understood for now
over a century since the seminal work of
Ramona caja and much of the research
they ask questions of perhaps the
morphology when one analyzes with our
neurons in different species or
different developmental stages or upon
manipulation that can be due to
illogical injuries or pharmacological
interventions and although there are
neurons that are different because there
belong to different types we always have
to remember that in biology no two
objects are exactly the same and so
there is an important question of asking
whether neurons and their shapes belong
to continue or they form distinct paths
and to paraphrase Orwell's Animal Farm I
would say that each neuron is different
but some neurons are more different than
others and mathematicians have come up
with method to understand groupings of
objects that are similar but not
identical and one of these methods
discussed our analysis the idea is to
represent parameters of the shape for
example the total length of the arm or
the number of branches or the volume
invaded by the branch in structure and
plot those in a multi-dimensional state
and because every neuron is different no
two neurons will occupy the exact same
position in space but they will tend to
form cloud dusters
those are what correspond to more flawed
so in order to do this in large scale
and with there is matic approaches
s is the early days of neuroscience
cahal had already defined the process or
constructing the shape of neuron the
three major steps with our label lately
visualization and tracing the heart be
that mostly with both labeling and
Pacifico purchase any of become white
fuel
and then hand tracing and salami since
that unit has developed a variety of
sophisticated aesthetic methods or
tabling or visualization and priest
being has prepared to computerized
patient that allow the three-dimensional
representation of each and every
position of preaching point in space so
that the arbor it represented a series
of Beckert a very much the protein can
be represented instructor as theories of
mesh accordion in the case of Herat is a
series of p dimensional coordinates are
connected in art so many years ago in
2006 we launched a resource called euro
more for a dork to host and in all
digital reconstructions of neuronal and
not Lea morphology collected by hundreds
of different laboratories worldwide from
any and hospice his brain turn her
mental condition and start type and at
this point in in 2020 with past over
120,000 veterans and these neurons are
unloaded a dark variety of labs for
great diversity studies and these
reconstructionist have quite a bit of
detail in their branch tracker but the
or press the feature of databases in
fact it growing size
truly allows for Integrative studies
that would not be possible in individual
so in the latest version that was
released at member there are about a
hundred twenty thousand euros from 250
bats 14 million trace things have been
downloaded from pretty much an trees
list and in the United Nations are from
not only the most common auto species
red eyes applies but pretty much any
filler from elegans to humans and this
is based on a little shorter continuous
literature spurt which now contains on
over 43
thousand bracelet and we're now going
towards 2000 that is published based on
data or distracting data from the remote
for the door and now there are also
hundreds of NIH grants that are funded
based on a data from the remoter org
from 255 PI's many universities at
hundred millions of dollars so mostly
the reconstructions of papers produced
or modeling for comparative morphometric
analysis or studies of potential
connectivity and for visualization and
educational since the beginning however
it shows in academia and in biomedical
research we're not the only ones for
data for many years his data have been
used for variety of spam and art
applications including flight math
limpia neuroscience for kids variety of
artistic renderings including audio
visual representations or a pay on
vacation and many more and the most
recent application is in aiding SL
senses or the brain initiative sources
so the database is maintained through
continuous pipeline of processes start
from searching the leader identified
data and we have an ongoing continuous
data base third further amputated with
the combination of language being
automated parsing and notation in the
same data third we also analyzed report
of the users of the data but we can then
return the authors and put the funding
agencies it updates on the usage of
resource we then request the data at the
beginning a minority of data there now
a Brockman 80% of our requests are
honored by the authors over receive the
data and we process this data to
standard item it to an open non
proprietary format but we also check for
comment inconsistent between data files
that I defect bounce criminality
we also annotate the metadata from the
data path that we received linking
mapped evidence in the first / and then
we update the schema of the database to
make sure that data are searchable by
metadata as well as by party
finally we release the data first on a
new site so that we allow we allow
authors and our technical staff check
that the data are complete and finally
the public when we then please and all
the data that we release is open spokes
open access so it's completely free to
the users and it's Mirrorball know
so the delivery valve is what's possible
through normal for a tour by Paris it
currently know that because the mass of
the data are increases exponentially it
means that most of the data from the
most recent and not only that by the
complexity of the data it also changing
and increasing over time so most of data
from the early days days where from the
injury reconstruction from slide and we
followed the data from recent times
including from the ice dam project
include austin predict and full external
wreck instructions with prostitute most
of the cabling so in the second part of
my talk about atop a method to analyze
retrograde fracture is big data in order
to classify external back in a way that
is complimentary the root first neuron
and the idea here is that every brain
region especially cortical brain and in
mammalian brains projects good part and
this reviews from my
dropping PPP so if the region a
protected to a target region B it means
that there is at least one neuron type
it's still allocated a Zack some movie
and basically depending on how one
parses naturally of brain in how many
parcels on how many picture the number
of the target regions for a given force
with known will change but for the
cortex for Maine Spain atlases this
number is typically between 10 and over
30 and these are examples of the
resources from which some of these data
were taken including the iconic top at
Conway mansion so what kind of external
architecture the single neuron level can
such the microscope be the macro state
this regional thing so that could be one
neuron type for each target region so
every neuron type might project to a
single region and target regions that
might be m1 could also envision its
single neuron type that proud that is
connect it to all and are the regions
and of course there are many in tween
cases that afford those who have studied
these projections are much more
realistic which is a term mediate number
of neuron type that will project to a
subset of the target area and our point
of view is that if two neurons project
to to that area they represent different
paths to the fact the network in
different way so this is a form of
neuronal function now it might be simple
or too simple to classify neurons
very purely picked on their own of
production target but it's really not
very spin even if one simplify the
entire human brain structure in simply
double bottom right left front back or
if you like or load over bilateral right
and left a structure so this is the
equivalent approximating the whole brain
with two by two by two to now consider
not Malcolm X power production it will
be simply a binary that eighth element
and so we can compare to
as to back birth of elephants each in
these vectors I binary where as zero
means that even neuron does not jack to
a given story who live in target and one
means that the finger on project but
this cases are two five factors that are
not the same represent two neurons are
projected to different sub that is two
by two by two so even in this very
simple representation the number of
possible neuron Kyle you can't force the
publication it's a times two to the
eighth minus one or two thousand and
forty nine types just out of it by two
pi q qf1 can stay approximately as and
different brain regions that are a lot
in modern anatomic first elation and one
does the same calculation this would
obtain a number of neuron types that is
far greater than the total number of
neurons in and in all species of all
animals in the entire known universe and
the curve is in exponential so the truth
is not all possible paths that exist for
a given part per given source and a
given brain instead on this top set of
passes is typically found in a new our
region for example if we do get a
critical region projecting to static
target regions perhaps only twenty of
the hundred twenty seven your own class
and knowing which classes are present
which classes do not expect not only
that but also how many neurons there are
in each class that beta cell this
challenge for atomic so how can we top
that anatomical challenge and that there
are many Institute agencies especially
interested in there including the US
Preventive the European human brain
project and also massive art scale
industrial
initiatives including at the Allen
Institute at Amelia for Mouse light and
the brains math so one possibility is
reconstruct all the neurons and that
production and this is something that is
very time-consuming and labor-intensive
great product on automation however this
process is now very hittable
but even if work who records back only a
representative sample stay a dozen or so
stars for each cloud this put in fact
demand and impractical not construction
and he would probably still me rarest
type the neurons the neutron production
type for which there he would not only
that but this operation would that need
to be repeated for every third feature
in the brain and suppose one is
interesting the entirely to paint that
they a thousand stores regions this
would require multiplication in so as an
alternative we can think of a thought
experiment based on Conway's debate
retrograde production which is suppose
that we can inject an arbitrary number
of different colors a retro friendly in
all the regions of the brain that's
color those sequences p.m. for the
hemp-beater
and then what we can do is simply go to
the source region and count the number
of cells that are colored each unique
combination of cod and if they were
doable we could even do that
automatically in a very expedient way
and we would be able to determine the
number of neurons with each project
however this thought experiment has two
major limitation one is that in practice
we can only do multiple retro
professional to a limited number of
reiden and the second is that when we
inject
retributive a label we only hit part of
the target region in other words an only
label attraction exists in fiber in not
105 to per bound to miss of the top in
the soup so stark and project onyx is
the way to tackle these charges and to
explain how that works and start the
simplest aid which is a return
protective for target regions and was
for and this only has 15 projects right
and because there are 15 episode to
manually draw them all
in PowerPoint and so these are
color-coded stay type fun only
protection type 15 projects to all over
target beach and so let's now imagine
that we only have three retrograde pod
in North Pole so we can design or
experiment in each experiment we will
leave out one of our visions so let all
the three colors being red and blue and
let's remember that when we hit a target
who will not get 100% of the target who
will only hit a fraction so for every
experiment we'll run then for experiment
who have a combination of three copper
and the possible combinations of three
colors if rise happen if bring only
green only read only blue red and green
red and blue green and blue red green
and blue so which of these 15 pounds
contribute I'm sorry which of the 15
neuron tides country out of the neurons
that are dust color B but first or are
all the cells that are green must
project the target of what otherwise
that would not be green however remember
that not all the neurons of projected
target one green because we're only
hitting a fraction of one that 81 is the
Frank but we can say chip equals p1 and
p1 but people on the count of the
project to target but that's not an
because we're not putting any color in
target part of all the neuron type
projects the both target 1 and target
also going to be green we have add also
8 1 times v1 which is a number of
protection type that hits both target 1
and 4 but that's also not enough because
we also have neurons that project 1 and
2 but they're in the penumbra of the
fraction of the stars that invade that
are not picking up the red and now you
get the trio we do the same for pond and
three four one two and three were both
two and three are in the penumbra and
all of the bomb that also hit or for
which were completely block so we can
write it's very complex
and for each of these four experiments
and similarly right they have attached a
patient one equation for each of the
populations of other so we have four
experiment seven equations for each
experiments which made point eight how
many unknowns we have well we have
fifteen unknowns which are the numbers
of neurons in each type and then we also
have the fractions of colors that are
picked up those K 1 K 2 K 3 parameter we
have three of those unknowns for each of
four experiments so 12 unknowns so we
have a total of 27 and 28 equation we
can put the system with 28 equations in
27 knowns the numerical occupied there
and let the computer crank the numbers
and find possible solutions so we did
computational analysis of this using
evolutionary algorithm and surrogate
data and these data are just in fact can
reconstruct correct pattern of data
robustly in a variety of different
scenario and with minimal error meaning
ever below 5% with a limited number of
experiments approximate 5
experimentation so we're now starting to
analyze data from the Don black where
they in fact are able to do triple
retrograde injections in a very routine
way but also quadruple injections with
some effort and they're now testing and
piloting ability of doing quintuple
injections but this is now a very
exciting time because we might be able
to have actual numbers of count or
prototype and just as a reminder because
things were expecially the system is
quite powerful way that bass player is
quadruped objection which you can are
doable with currently we could resolve
fire fairly easily projections for our
12 regions now remember the number of
neuron types for regions is of the order
of 2 to the top which is approximately
4,000
in Europe a staggering number of neurons
the most important think of this peak is
that it's feel very well because once
you're counting neurons and you're
slicing brains and in fact no cannot a
single scores but any of the sources
that are projecting to the same nations
of Earth so especially in the supported
this might allow you to resolve the
neuronal census problem critical sources
with the thinset host I'm going to
appear another two sources of funding
multi NIH from both the brain initiative
the Vista program and discussed in an
elaborate research in computational
neuroscience program as well as a
traffic foundation philanthropic Medical
Foundation and private support from
North America location well as a variety
of past funding from government agencies
including NIH the National Science
Foundation Duty such as the Office of
Naval Research Earthforce and and the
last I would like to acknowledge the
contribution of members of enter here
First Nation typically for the project
that I highlighted in this presentation
and linguist and equal er are the
leaders of normal for org and of the
network analysis in my lab and among the
th student mass to dark rum and fish no
matter where i Pam by Jerry are very
much fueling the progress in your more
for d'Or and FIFA Venkatesh find all the
evolutionary hydrants improve his
ability of I'll stop here but all the
data are available online and I'm also
available for I my name is Tim Duke l'm
from UCSD thank you very much for this
opportunity
you only heard from wrong way and you do
about the large scale analysis of the
neural connectivity so my talk is a
little different mine is more focus
on the specific on our circuitry says
you know the brain is the connection of
the many different cell types so I mean
the many different cell type meaning
that there are tons of different cell
type connecting to the different cell
type we don't let me know how they are
actually different and you know other
problem is not just cell type is
connection it means that how the
different cells are connected what type
of cell type is actually really puzzling
and without fully understanding that
cell type specific dimension it may be
really difficult to understand how
brains send the information together so
connection you know in brain connection
is synapse each neuron has more than you
know thousand synapse meaning that
connected a thousand different target
and then number and the specificity of
the synaptic connection is very
important and especially the price we
control the viewing the development and
the changing the synaptic connection
meaning that strength of the synaptic
connection change is actually the
fundamental unit of the information
processing underlying memory and other
you know decision-making so it's very
important to understand the connection
of different cell type in like synapse
specific matter so how many talk about
the most amazing work that actually try
to identify the projection of individual
cell in the protests and the other brain
area but at this moment all the
information we are having is actually
where those neuron projection so they
are at you're looking at the axonal
fiber so I thought that we need to have
a tool to differentiate that's on fiber
and synaptic Bhutan in the same young to
really understand the anatomical
organization the other problem is the
brain is actually a very heterogeneous
even in the same brain area
so we never get the right panel here I
labeled in primary court in Iran
predicting to those only go straight on
with the green by injecting retrograde
virus expressing green fluorescence
protein Hinda though so me go straight
on and then I'll aim both in your own
predicting to toe the latter straight on
with the red fluorescence so when you
look at the primary motor cortex there
are not much of segregation there is but
more likely their incoming go in the
similar brain area so it's a little
difficult to differentiate on the neural
population based on the prediction it's
a lot of effort has been done and still
going on to generate the transgenic
animal is pressing clearly companies
under the specific promoter prints you
know marking the specific cell type in
cortex so there are a lot of like lists
of the trend getting animal experts in
creating and marking the difference down
time but still you know the H same cell
neuron same same time your unlabeled by
discrete line may actually project the
same brain area so we need to find a
tool to define the you know the cell
type and prediction specific manner so
this is very daunting so meaning that
you have to have a specific tool
especially in the Bairro to the label
the specific cell type and specific
protection so to understand to apply
this tool we actually study the basal
ganglia so my lab has been studying the
role of the basal ganglia and the
movement disorder and the
decision-making so this slide is that
like a very classical diagram of the
basal ganglia from straitens Globus
pallidus and telomers and cortex so I
guess this um diagram has been used for
more than 20 years but the well I'm keep
studying the role of the basal ganglia
beginning to realize that diagram and
circuit organization is not as simple as
this diagram especially their synaptic
Nationals very difficult I'm very
actually different than actually
proposed so in this you know
presentation we're focusing on the
Globus pallidus the Globus pallidus is
covered in your population actually more
than 60% of the neural net are popomon
positive so using the publicly animal
which can define the Globus pallidus
neuron expressing I mean as a solo
marker we developed the virus tool
expressing red fluorescence protein to
mark the cell body and the axon fiber
and the sanctifying tappity fkh can mark
the presynaptic terminal specifically so
we inject this virus which expressing
this protein and create a pendant matter
into the Globus pallidus of poetry
animal and then we found that actually
yes they are projecting to many
different target conventionally they're
predicting you know conventional diagram
I'm only talking about the stuff telemon
it clears stn but we found him in a
different area projected by this
following positive neuron in the Globus
pallidus so what we know when we look at
a little gift structure and yes each
close thousand your Omega C epsilon to
each others and then we are able to
differentiate that one fiber and the
synaptic Ponte based on the green and
the red persons per thing when you go to
the other brain area become more obvious
that STM you know that this is stop
telling me nucleus there fiber and the
synaptic connection can be clearly
differentiated and when you look at this
in our area you can even you know look
at the cell shape of the postsynaptic
cell just by looking at the to prison a
victim you know made by the Globus
pallidus power linear and then this is a
whole session copper column is showing
that just by looking at perhaps on fiber
it may be really difficult to understand
that their actual connection by
singhania and then they've become very
more obvious when you do the 3d
structure
so here we show that the same cell time
genetically deploying the same cell type
power and past Amir and Globus pallidus
projected to many different target right
so this actually we were able to achieve
with this specific viral tool expressing
red fluorescence protein in the cell
body in axon terminal and the in a green
Kanta at the synaptic off you know don't
know so we know that this neuron
I mean genetically defined the same
population in Globus pallidus project
management target but we have a very
specific question okay it's possible the
same year and predicted many different
target and different population here on
projected a different oh sorry to
understand the function of the Globus
pallidus overall the basal ganglia in
identifying this two possibility I'm
differentiating these two possibilities
very important then question is how can
we differentiate this genetically
defined through different population may
project the different target so we
engineered the virus nectary to we
engineer the rabies virus so you know
that l-ladies virus is a very potent
electric ray tracer and how many you've
already share the many of beautiful data
that labeled by the rabies virus it's
important for the retrograde infection
but and I expressed transgene very high
level but it's in this toxic study so
you cannot use for long period of time
so property of the retrograde
transduction is mainly because of lack
of protein on the surface of the rabies
virus so using the idea we actually see
the time the lentivirus from course
equine infectious anemia virus CIA being
so every pseudo type is you know
yeah the virus with like a protein of
the rabies so this virus can go retro
greatly by infecting the absent final
and then it has a DNA gene genome in the
viral particle so it can generate this
stable expression of the transgene
doesn't cure the cell so it you can be a
long-term study with this file - so
using this idea we actually further
modified that in a genome of the virus
so we actually using the flip the
combination to create companies
combination so we generate the ready
great retro grade uranium virus
expressing flip the combinations in pre
dependent manner so when this virus is
in taking to the target area there will
be little gradually transduce tada
in a presynaptic cell then only the cell
expressing tree will express fully and
then when we express when you inject the
AAP virus expressing transgene inflicted
pendant manner so on it on your own
predicting this target will actually
express distrusting so when we inject
this virus combination so when you
inject the retrograde eia be expressing
CREB with combination treatment on
marrying to the snr and then injecting
AAV expressing gfp in with dependent
manner into da the girls pallidus the
problem in tree animal today to
differentiate other population waiting
that this same approach to retrograde
AAP expressing public companies in
create a pendant manner into the part of
vascular nucleus and then injecting a
avi forcing party opinion with the
pendant marrying to the ghost elitism
the album entry animal when we do that
we found that the neuron projecting to s
NR a-- you know doesn't go to the f SQ a
nucleus you know we also found that
Globus pallidus neuron
Globus pallidus follow me and I'm
predicting to fine fescues nucleus
doesn't go to this NR Oresteia so as you
can see in the first panel actually the
location of the our cell predicting
different target are actuated or
different within even within the Globus
pallidus this give you the clear idea
that even even though genetically the
same population based on where they
project to they can be totally different
circuit
but this one is like you're looking at
the group you know looking at the group
of the neuron so we actually thought
that to fully understand anatomical
organization they're actually individual
their projection or the organization of
individual neuron is very important to
be in them so to get a single neuron
tracing we actually applied them in a
new technique so to get the single
neuron tracing you get we need to get
the higher education image and then also
they have to detect a fanatic biltong
and we have to get the reliable for
essence labelings because you know if
you lose the fluorescence you will not
leave you know trace the neuron and
there is a better to image the whole
brain with the high resolution very fast
so he was a dream for a long time but
our collaborator Guanzhong in MIT
developed a new tissue processing method
called showed and map basically the
preacher fluorescence signal and expand
the tissue so we can get in a highly
duration imaging I would really evolved
for enslavement
so using this approach we injected the
virus we proposed before into the Globus
pallidus of Powerlink reanima and then
we did shield and map processing you
know and if we clear the brain and
expand the brain while triggering the
signal a good thing about this message
is the well you know while we can see
the endogenous person's protein we can
keep doing immunostaining and in situ
hybridization so we can actually get the
labeled
signal as well as stealth eimacher with
the immunostaining and fluorescence
microscope so here is the hi
legitimately require of the Globus
pallidus neuron I'm asking you I'm
protecting to many different target and
then we take the one you're on and we'd
actually built a single neuron tracing
and trace that is the gray line insect
occur absent fiber traced man kind of
manually and then while we're doing
we are able to do in situ hybridization
to actually the MARTA SNR in Iran with
many different cell type marker so after
the in situ
after the single neuron tracing we
actually get this kind of diagram so
showing the one year on make a samsung
the government in Iran in the Globus
pallidus and then axon is projected snr
and then actually make a realistic
synapse onto the ten more neuron in
their Sena so this high resolution
imaging of the single neuron enable else
to trace a single neuron level and then
we are able to get the full actually the
organization in the long range
projecting neuron in cell types best
being met so one more step forward
because we know that there's two
different population with predicting the
different target may belong to the
different anatomical organization but in
our study also showed that that this
Junior on actually has a different
electrophysiological property so looks
like they are different anatomically and
functionally so we thought that they may
belong to the different brain wide
circuitry right so we actually thought
use this other viral tool so using the
same retrograde yeah in the virus
expressing to the companies in pretty
pendant manner into the center or part
of vascular nucleus and then we injected
too many helper virus to label the are
to get the monosynaptic rabies virus
infection so inject a V virus expressing
TVA in fluid dependent manner or into
the gross a leaders of the Falcon 3
animal
and then later we inject a pseudo type
rabies virus expressing tip into the
Globus pallidus so we are able to label
the power passed Amir and Globus
pallidus only projecting to SN R or PF
in the event when we analyze the whole
brain cell distribution we found that
the neuron projecting to you
you know peeping you're in the Globus
pallidus are actually different based on
the word of those close Pelican neuron
project you sober all this I provide
many different viral tool and then I
this is a short summary that the using
viral tool we are able to differentiate
the axon fiber and synaptic Bouton's I
think that is very important to fully
understand anatomical organization of
the specific neuron and then using a
noble tissue processing mustachioed and
math together with the single neuron
tracing we are able to get the highly
deletion single neuron are committing
single neuron processing in the most
reliable manner so I don't have a
ethnology slide here but you know this
work is done by collaboration with the
Penguins young as I mention and then
also da you know you know my lab members
are in UCSD yeah thank you for the
outstanding presentation for additional
panels on the NIH brain initiative a
multi disciplinary approach to
neuroscience please do to our agenda on
our events page as a final reminder the
panelists will follow up with any
questions you've submitted beam thank
you again for your participation